we always saw Archie running around the
garden at Frogmore Cottage and maybe
jumping in the Queen's Pond that was all
part of our future and everything
changed really really quickly
since Harry and his wife Meghan Markle
left their Frogmore Cottage residence
for California King Charles officially
evicts them from the Royal Estate
they've shown absolutely no willingness
to reconcile I would like to get my
father back I would like to have my
brother back a spokesperson for the Duke
and Duchess of Sussex confirms they've
been requested to vacate their residents
and have until early summer to do it the
move is to allow Charles's brother
prince Andrew to live there it's unclear
who delivered the eviction notice
however it is known it was at the
directive of the king
suddenly have my grandmother go there's
a house
Frogmore Cottage
it's available are you interested
yes please yes Frogmore Cottage became
Harry and Megan's official home in 2019.
it was a place where we had so many
memories
from our courtship our engagement our
wedding our walks and then where we
ended up you know having our baby
following their move to California in
2020 Frogmore was the only place for the
couple to have security for them and
their two kids Archie and a little bit
while they visited England we know that
it was always their intention
pre-pandemic that they would travel back
to the UK on a relatively regular basis
now clearly things have been difficult
family relations have been strained
Charles's Royal shake-up comes amid
tension following the release of Harry's
Memoir spare and the couple's Netflix
documentary
it was terrifying to have my brother um
Scream and Shout at me and my father say
things that just simply weren't true and
and my grandmother you know quietly sit
there and sort of take it all in William
is said to be privately seething and and
devastated by his brother and what he
has done in this autobiography and the
King well I think he simply can't
believe what his youngest son has done a
source sells E.T that Harry's
relationship with his father is broken
while another source says it has never
been worse Charles is extremely
disappointed in what was shared in the
book including how Harry was
disrespectful to his wife Camilla The
Source adds you can't expect to act that
way without consequences I think for
Harry to have targeted Camilla in the
way that he has you know into painter is
the villain in this narrative I think
that will be hurtful for Charles and the
question is has a line been crossed here
but the run-up to the coronation to be
overshadowed by these Headlines by Harry
and Megan in this Royal rival court and
over in America is problematic so really
a Reconciliation is going to be in the
best interest of the firm whether that's
a real and meaningful and long-lasting
Reconciliation well that's the million
dollar question can that actually happen
foreign